[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
whining and crying
about the crimes that he's done that
he'll be prosecuted for
loving Putin Xi Jinping
Kim Jong-un all the same old [__] right
it's just funny that Tucker Carlson had
to sit there and pretend to be
interested
I mean he Tucker Carlson pulled out all
the stops to act like he was impressed
but with this [__] buffoon was saying
last night
really really
doing his best
to not passionately hate that
[__] it was uh it's something
else we're going to show you some clips
of that today
um as the Cheeto dust cueing on her
goes on Fox news with Tucker Carlson to
um
I don't know whine some more
Infamous supporters sick of him being a
[__] victim yet Jesus Christ you
think you think the the snowflake [__]
your feelings this you're a snowflake
crowd would be sick and tired of hearing
him [__] and moan about the [__] he
caused don't you think
I don't know maybe they'll get over it
eventually I doubt it but we'll find out
speaking about finding out [__]
around and finding out Jim Jordan
is being sued by the Manhattan D.A Alvin
Bragg
Ed and it's uh it's actually they hired
a law firm firm to sue uh Jim Jordan and
the Judiciary Committee I think Jim
Jordan is going to [__] around and find
out maybe get some uh hang some catch a
case on obstruction guards charges what
do you think
oh yeah listen if you if you believe
that Donald Trump and Jim Jordan haven't
been coordinating
um these these subpoenas
that the Judiciary Committee is trying
come on man come on
Jim Jordan's supposed to be in New York
in the next week I think the 17th so in
five days maybe maybe just maybe there
should be a pair of handcuffs waiting
for him in some obstruction charges I
don't know I'm just saying I'm just
throwing ideas out there into the
universe maybe they'll come true
uh we have news in the Louisville
shooting
of course of course it was an AR-15
obviously why wouldn't it be why he
bought it days before
he carried out the shooting of course he
did
he shot a law enforcement officer in the
head of course he did why would he shoot
the law enforcement officer in body
armor he grazed another law enforcement
officer that law enforcement officers
fighting for his life
because the state of Kentucky and this
country can't come to grips with you
can't just let anyone have a gun
whenever the [__] they won it's not a
thing we should do
especially weapons of war I mean frankly
what we should do is Ban all assault
weapons and confiscate them and melt
them down I mean it's it's getting to
the point to where we have to have real
[__] Solutions here red flag laws and
background checks they're not willing to
do that so maybe we should start the
negotiating point I'm melting all those
[__] down into blocks of Steel
I'm just saying maybe that's where we
start out at
I'm telling you he he was suicidal he
had mental issues and they just bloody
may have a gun because anyone can have a
gun right anyone can get a gun have a
gun carry a gun and for whatever purpose
doesn't matter doesn't matter he
obviously bought this gun to kill people
and to commit suicide by cop with this
gun obviously that is what happened he
got it days before he carried out this
mass shooting at this Bank in Louisville
where Rick Scott's her best friend was
[__] out of here
so so so the teachers in in Nashville
weren't someone's best friend sister
aunt
mom grandmother those children weren't
someone's grandchildren Brothers sister
come on give me a [__] break man
I mean we're we're gonna have to we're
gonna have to do a couple things
to figure this [__] out
one is we're gonna have to just be
posting pictures of these dead bodies
all over media I'm I I'm telling you
the world the world needs to come to
grips what the [__] going on
not just when it affects their Community
or when someone they know is affected by
mass shooting we need to know the
ramifications of this [__]
it's enough of this garbage
and we need to be talking about we need
to talk about to the two-way Bros and
come at them hard hey we're not we're
not only going to ban assault weapons
we're gonna come get your [__]
[__]
you've been talking about it for decades
how we're going to come get your guns
and that ain't what we've been saying
for decades we haven't been saying that
two [__] decades
almost two decades since the assault
weapons ban
expired
now we should [__] start saying the
[__]
that's what we should start saying it
we're not only going to ban your [__]
guns we're going to come get them [__]
it's enough of this stuff it's enough of
this [__] it's not this nonsense we're
we're starting off we're like oh red
flag laws [__] that [__] not do
something do it all
that's what we should be doing not do
this person was suicidal
had a lot of issues
that he was dealing with
and in our country
he was allowed to go get a gun
immediately
immediately to go carry out his acts of
violence
because of his unstable mind
now you say well red flag laws would
prevent that background checks [__] that
[__] ban those [__] I don't
give a [__] what kind of profit how much
money they make I don't care if it
drives the handful of of gun
manufactured families into poverty I
don't give a [__]
it's enough of this [__]
I don't care who carries it out why they
did it I don't give a [__] anymore and
America should not give a [__]
what the circumstances on each and
individual mass shooting is do you
understand how [__] much brain power
it would take and how much research it
would take on a daily basis for each
American to break down each mass
shooting you dumb sons of [__]
let alone the [__] the other gun
violence that isn't mass shootings in
this country
it's the guns you stupid bastards it's
the [__] guns
you take the guns out of every single
one of these equations
and you have less stacks of dead bodies
that's just the [__] fact
and when America finally plucks its head
out of its ass and realizes hey you know
what
the Second Amendment thing is our Second
Amendment it's ours it's like the
majority of us we're all we're all the
government we get to say what the [__]
is and what the [__] isn't
and this whole both sides this [__] it's
the same [__] I watch I watch [__] uh
Senator whatever the [__] his name is I
think it's Turner and in the uh
the the the
eight
the clan of eight
in Congress
talking about classified documents both
sides and [__]
on the documents case and on Gun reform
you [__] you
saying that Democrats and liberals in
this country don't want to restrict who
owns what weapons you are full of
[__] garbage
well Democrats no Democrats Democrat
demon
the president United States right now
has said send me a [__]
an assault weapons ban and I'll sign it
it's what he said he would do it
now you may say well Tony he knows no
one will do that
what the [__] does it matter
the only reason why they won't do it is
because we keep giving them permission
not to
we it's us we're the [__] government
not them
we hire these [__]
it's our government it is us until we
get this through our thick skulls that
we are the government it is us they only
represent our vote that's it period and
they have term limits they're coming up
in 2024 folks so what are you gonna do
are you going to keep these stupid
[__] still in office are you
gonna hire some [__] in these
Republican seats that are willing to
talk
about anything but thoughts and prayers
when you have stacks of dead bodies that
are ripped apart by weapons of war
[__] out of here man
both parties are the same [__] get the
[__] out of here with that nonsense
there was a transgender person that shot
up a school in Louisville Christian
School in Louisville and in the entirety
of the country when it's the guns do
something with the guns Jesus Christ
protesters
seized on the capitol to yell and scream
for them to do something
and they explode expelled to black men
out of the legislators out of the out of
out of the house
of Tennessee
for being black they saw the opportunity
so that's why they did it they saw the
opportunity to do it that's the only
read they don't like they don't like
those uppity boys
Justin Jones Justin Pearson so they
expel them
because they're black
man got nothing to do with ain't got
nothing to do with their protesting gun
reform not a goddamn thing
Republicans don't give a [__] about your
protesting gun reform they don't give a
[__] if you hold signs or you're loud
they don't give a [__] the NRA's money
and the gun lobbies money is a hell of a
lot is a hell it's a hell of a it drowns
out a lot of noise it drowns out a lot
of noise it's a lot of money it's a lot
of influence it's a lot of power
so whose government is it
is it the gun lobbies
is it the gun manufacturers the handful
of gun manufacturers
that a few families benefit from in this
country or is it us
every time every [__] time there is a
mass shooting where the shooter has
intended to kill as many people as
possible they go buy the weapons where
they can easily
which is almost anywhere
without fail they're not using AR-15s by
happenstance
you think you think race car drivers
drive fast cars by happenstance
hmm
you think that's a thing they're just
like you know what
we might as well drive the fastest car
might as well
just so happens that we have one sitting
here and it's available if it wasn't we
drive the slow cars you people are
[__] dumb
they're going and buying these weapons
of war to kill as many human beings as
they possibly can that's that's why
it's not [__] complicated understand
it's easy [__] logic I mean Jesus
Christ the gun manufacturers make sure
that these these weapons are
manufactured to his kill as many [__]
human beings as possible in as little as
amount of time that's the whole design
of them
just like a [__] a race car is
designed engineered and built to go fast
what a coinkydink
so ban them ban them and take them from
you stupid bastards and melt them down
and anyone out there who's against
background checks red flag laws or any
kind of reasonable gun safety at all
just the reasonable stuff not I'm not
talking about the confiscation I'm
talking about reasonable gun reform and
you're against it and you're publicly
against it you say it you are now
flagged you are you are the person that
we are should red flag
if you don't think there should be
common sense gun safety and gun reform
you you should be red flagged
immediately and law enforcement should
come get your [__] weapons because
you're a danger to our society I don't
give a [__] I'm tired of it I'm [__]
tired of it I'm tired of talking about
it I'm tired of listening to it on the
news I'm tired of our countrymen I don't
give a [__] who they are our countrymen
getting torn down and ripped apart by
weapons of war we can [__] do
something about it
it's us folks it's us
[__] [__] the politicians it's not
them vote them the [__] out
if they don't like it [__] vote for
the their opponent [__] them fire em
[__] them
so not for this garbage [__]
and yeah we should start again we should
start the negotiations of melting down
every single one of those [__]
other countries have done it Australia
did it in the 1990s and it worked they
still don't have mass shootings
still to this day
what could it possibly be
they do not allow their citizenry just
to run around with whatever [__]
weapons they want
whenever they want and get them how they
want
with no backstops at all
because they don't want their citizenry
murdered by their citizenry just for
pure blooded profit okay
it's not complicated it really isn't
it's not [__] hard to understand
these things and the two-way Bros boy
they're gonna go Cody you [__] trees
in this piece of [__] don't you know
what the Second Amendment blah blah blah
yakety smackity
coming at me with all kinds of foot it's
our freedom all right blah blah blah
yakity [__] smackity shut the [__] up
you weak ass little [__] 2A [__]
that's right I'm talking to you
you [__] who think oh my my
rats can't be infringed the [__] they
can't dummy we we as the government
infringe on your rights every [__]
day you're you do not have the right to
do whatever you want when you want white
dude you just don't and that's part of
the [__] problem is the white gun
culture in this country it actually is
the [__] problem
I mean even if we get rid of guns we're
still gonna have this white gun culture
here's here's the white gun culture
here it is
are you ready I've said it before are
you ready I'm gonna say it turn turn the
[__] volume up
any problem you got can be solved by a
gun that's the culture
any problem any of it I don't give a
[__] what problem you got any problem
you got can be solved by a gun
that's the white gun culture that's what
happened in [__] Louisville
he had a problem he went and got the
problem solver he can get one in
Kentucky no one says a [__] thing and
he went and he solved his problem
with a gun
people are still going to have problems
if we take away guns
they just won't be able to [__] mow
down dozens of people
now I have to be a little more creative
maybe we should get creative and fun not
not just gun reform but fun [__]
mental health care quick
this white gun culture is a [__]
disease
I don't know maybe I'm off my rocker but
it really feels like it really feels
like if we have more mass shootings than
days
it really feels like we're at a point
where maybe we should look at this
and not even start having reasonable
discussions have unreasonable
discussions
unreasonable debate Let's Get Loud and
outrageous that's what I think
can you imagine if the entire country
was calling 60 70 percent of the country
was calling for confiscation and melting
of guns if that was the [__] call if
that was the debate if that was the
starting point
can you imagine where the negotiations
would end up
it's time to get radical folks it's time
to get outrageous and Loud [__] them
they don't they don't want to do red
flag laws then fine we'll take your [__]
then
it's enough of this it's [__] enough
of the dead bodies
it's enough of infringing on people's
right to live
and give a [__] what your 2A says
go read the other [__] 26 of them and
then we'll come back and we'll talk
about the second one when you understand
how many other amendments they are and
that their amendments
[__] turd
oh boy I mean I could yell and scream
about this all day
all [__] day all day tomorrow next
day and the day after that I mean as
long as this [__] keeps happening what
the hell else are we gonna do besides be
outrageous and loud
oh they're gonna [__] hate on me
people probably haven't been watching
The Champ people probably hate me in the
chat saying melting down the guns cops
skating getting them [__] get them
all [__] them [__] them [__] em [__]
them
[__] I don't give a [__] if you think
I'm off my rocker I don't give a [__]
I'm sick of the [__]
so you know what I'm gonna move the goal
post that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
move the goal post
every every [__] time this happens
I'm just gonna move the goal post
further and further and further they
move the goal post every [__] day
thoughts and prayers oh the reason why
we can't have gun for him is because
Democrats won't do it it's those damn
Democrats that won't that won't pass
sensible gun reform get the [__] out of
here
the president United States just signed
an executive order
just recently
and no telling how many lives it's
already saved and because that's the FI
that's the [__] crazy thing about
this whole [__] thing is that if we
did [__] if we actually did stuff and we
fired these [__] that won't
listen to us and we finally hired some
[__] that'll get off their ass
and do something about real [__]
problems like not [__] having bullets
fly around and Banks grocery stores
elementary schools or churches
we wouldn't know there would there would
be no data
to show
you got it
the only proof we would have is that
there's the lack of dead bodies right
now we just have stacks of them like we
have we have stacks of dead body data
more guns means more dead bodies that's
that's what it's equating to so we have
less guns we won't have dead bodies so
it it'll it'll be a little difficult to
convince the 2A [__] delusional cult
members at that point well they'll be
like well you can't prove
you can't prove that the reason why
there's a lack of dead bodies is a is
the assault weapons man get the man come
on we're not that goddamn stupid we're
not as stupid as you we're not as dumb
as you to think that we can't do
something about this
it's our [__] kids it's our
co-workers people we go to church with
God damn it's the strangers in the
grocery store literally literally that's
who's being [__] murdered
because we won't do something
and when I heard this morning that this
this guy in Louisville
had mental health care problems and that
he bought the gun day before I'm like oh
[__] here we go it's gonna be well we
should get him some Mental Health Care
well it's the mental illness the mental
illness went and bought the gun the
mental illness pulled the trigger the
mental illness the mental illness this
the mental illness that oh the mental
illness look
Fox almost every single person in this
country suffers from some sort of mental
illness and if you don't know that
you're you should be on [__] drugs
for one
just because you got mental problem
doesn't mean that you're a [__]
murderer
but it probably means that you shouldn't
have access to weapons that could make
you
a [__] mass murderer I don't know and
the only way it seems at this point to
get there is to move the goal post all
the way to the point to where we have no
[__] assault weapons at all none [__]
them
[__] them
I mean it'll totally cut the cartel's
legs out from underneath them you
[__] two eight Bros are always
yelling and screaming about the cartel
where do you think they get their
[__] guns
us you stupid [__]
the gun manufacturers make millions
every year off the guns and ammo that go
down to the cartel that you're terrified
of well we can't have the cartel have
guns they're brown people
it's just so [__] ridiculous
that we can't have these conversations
in a situation where we're like yeah
I'm I don't want to be shot at at a
sporting event at a concert at a grocery
store really at my job or my kids
elementary school or night it would just
be nice to not have to dodge [__]
bullets
from a high-powered [__] rifle that
would be cool
and it's getting to the point to where
you almost have to worry about this any
place you [__] go
you walk into a theater what's your
first thought well the movie's gonna be
great today but where am I gonna hide if
someone comes in here with a high proud
rifle you walk into a restaurant do we
really want to sit there because if
someone decides to come in here
and take their [__] their [__] out on
someone and solve a problem with a gun
in this restaurant do we really want to
be sitting there
it's gonna get to that point folks
it's gonna get to that point
believe me
it now it's up to us to do something
[__] these [__] politicians these
Republicans in these red States who have
bought and bought
by the gun lobby in there I ain't gonna
do [__]
they ain't gonna do [__] [__] no
Mike Turner was blaming it on Democrats
I'm not Jenny I'll show you the [__]
tape
he's saying it's Democrats fault the
reason why there isn't legislation
that's why get the [__] out of here man
almost every single Democrat in this
country is calling for some sort of gun
reform
every single [__] time there's a
shooting immediately Democrats get to a
microphone I do every [__] day take
them [__] it red flag background checks
don't want to have weapons of war we
don't need them [__] those things they
don't we don't need it in our [__]
society every day I don't care who the
shooter is who they shot who they killed
where it was at what building it was in
and rather it was on a beach
are at a concert or out in the opener in
a church grocery store Elementary School
High School College I don't give a [__]
it's the guns it's the [__] guns
dummies
it's not hard to understand this stuff
and trust me if you keep talking like
this like I am like just keep going at
it just chipping away and chipping away
and chipping away
the affiliation of that talk will win
it will win they won't be able to stop
it
I'm telling you
voters in this country vote on
affiliation I've told you that before
imagine imagine you being in that net
circle of 12 people at a party that I
talk about all the time where there's
one Trump Sport and he won't shut the
[__] up about Trump and how much he
wants to suck Trump off and he loves
Trump and oh man Trump's the god Trump's
a cold he's our cult leader I love him I
want to lick his balls
you know that guy you know what [__] I'm
talking about and everyone else in the
like I I'll I'll just go along and get
along
imagine if 10 of those people in that
[__] group of 12 were like [__] this
gun [__] get rid of this [__] [__] this
[__] we don't need to be we don't need
to have this this nonsense in our
country
that affiliation is going to spread far
and wide
you just gotta have the [__] courage
to say something [__] these idiots [__]
them [__] em [__] them and if you got a
gun and you hate this [__] go [__]
turn that son of a [__] in and have it
melted down [__] that goddamn gun you
don't need that [__] I know why a lot of
people are hanging on to them like oh
well well what if what if what if the
crazies decide to all band together and
turn I need to get and you don't need a
gun trust me you're not gonna need a gun
you're not going to need one it's it's
not a thing
when we do what we need to do you won't
need a [__] gun
you won't need one
you don't need one now
It Ain't Gonna Save you anyways
the [__] good guy with a gun got shot
in the [__] head
in Louisville he's fighting for his life
he was on the job four [__] days
the gun didn't save his life
the gun didn't save the other four
people the five people's lives I think
it's six people now [__] who knows
oh
let's get it together
let's cut the [__] [__] it's enough
of this garbage let's move the goal post
for these son of a [__]
let's stop saying just do something and
let's say let's take them [__] all of
them confiscate them melt them down get
rid of the [__] all of it and I think we
should televise it you goddamn right
just have [__] mountains of guns
to show these [__] that yeah we
will come get your [__]
so enough of this stuff they've been
saying we're gonna come get him for
years so let's do it [__] them [__] them
everyone stick around we'll be right
back I got these this interview to show
you
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
foreign
[Music]
that's right hide and seek I want to
tell you what hide and seek is going to
be so here's what we're trying to do
um when I add my seven day suspension
last month we we we were still
broadcasting to the up wires Channel
um over on up wire do you go to
upwire.com I mean give the graphic here
you can go to upright.com and you can
subscribe to the upwards Channel which
you should there's a lot of other
creators over on the up wire they they
put shorts on there some other videos
some other podcasts on the up wire so
you should go and check it out just go
to upright.com subscribe to their
Channel but tomorrow
this chat here will be moving to Gabe
Sanchez's YouTube channel are you
listening are you hearing me all you
people on the YouTube chat that love the
chat
hear me loud and clear we're going to go
over to Gabe Sanchez's YouTube channel
that's where we're going to chat
tomorrow we're gonna move the chat over
there so we'll be broadcasting from
Gabe's so it's called hide and seek but
you know I'm kind of giving you the uh
I'm kind of giving you
the hiding spot and the reason why is
because I want to go over there and get
Gabe Sanchez as many subscribers as we
can and the best way to do that is to
get you guys on
on his channel
and that that way that way you can
you can subscribe to his channel that's
important to me so make sure you're
going over and supporting Gabe Sanchez's
YouTube channel uh the the moderators
will be putting that link in the chat
but tomorrow when you find the YouTube
link
that's where it'll be so if if you're if
you're not subscribed to Gabe's YouTube
channel don't have the Bell notification
right
yes and some people are pointing out
that it's on Gabe's Channel right now
yes it is it is on Gabe's Channel today
I did that so that you guys could find
his channel so it's on his Channel right
now you if you want to go over there and
go over there and subscribe
um and then tomorrow we're gonna have
the entire chat there because that's the
only spot that it'll be broadcast from
YouTube now Our Fate our Facebook
viewers don't worry it's going to be on
Facebook it'll be on Twitch as well but
do me a favor if you're on Facebook or
twitch and you like YouTube or you watch
YouTube or you got a YouTube account go
subscribe to Gabe Sanchez's YouTube
channel also subscribe to ours if you're
not subscribed to ours and the up wire
might as well all three just go get
those this broadcast is right now
streaming to all three of those channels
you can actually probably just type in
Tony Michaels live in the YouTube
um
in the in the YouTube thing and it'll
show you these three broadcasts it's the
same one just on three different
channels so do me a favor go over to
Gabe Sanchez's YouTube channel find that
YouTube channel subscribe hit the Bell
notification you're going to want to do
that for tomorrow because tomorrow
that's where the chat will be that's
where we'll be airing on YouTube we're
just gonna try to get Gabe Sanchez as
many subscribers tomorrow as we can I'm
going to try this with some other
Creator we're going to see how it works
with Gabe
if it works we'll try to do it with um
some other
um some other content creators some
other channels try to get them some more
subscribers spread the love around a
little bit you know you guys are the
best audience in the world you're the
best chat and the the best chat they're
at in the world you guys are the [__] em
fam is the best there is
so I want to spread the love around and
and let the world have a taste of the
best audience in the world that's
important to me
um and I think it's important that we
amplify all these voices and all these
channels I'd rather be the up wire Gabe
Sanchez this one here and I feel like if
I give some love maybe I'll get it back
you know what I mean so because our
Channel my channel is not monetized
because of my [__] mouth mainly and
I'm gonna try to get it back maybe
eventually
um YouTube won't be able to resist to
sell that many ads as many views as
we're getting and we're up in views
we're almost to 200 000 views in the
last 28 days uh I believe I believe
we're at 5.2 million minutes viewed in
the last 28 days
um so
you guys are a dedicated loyal audience
to come here every day and listen to
this show
so why not spread the love around you
know what I mean I I'm I'm a I I am a
very generous person I'm not a greedy
person uh so I want to um I want to help
anybody I can and Gabe Sanchez being our
co-host
um and and the uh
the Mexican hunk of Love here on the
Tony Michaels podcast as some of the
Chatters knowing then um then we'll
we'll give him some love so make sure
again tomorrow we're gonna call it hide
and seek tomorrow we'll be broadcasting
from Gabe Sanchez's YouTube channel the
Tony Michaels podcast is going to move
over there for the day now we're over
there right now we're broadcasting from
there right now so it's easier to find
today so that way you're prepared for
tomorrow if that makes sense that's why
I did that
um
but make sure you you're subscribed to
his channel and click that Bell
notification so you know what chat to be
in tomorrow so if you can't find me
tomorrow
on YouTube that's where we are at now
some Roderick calls it podcast field
trip yeah podcast field trip hide and
seek whatever whatever you want to call
it
it doesn't bother me
doesn't bother me uh Tracy says You Wish
patreon sent notifications I think it
does I think if you go and you download
the app Tracy
if you go download the app on your phone
you can set your phone to send push
notifications from patreon I believe the
patreon app will send you those push
notifications Tracy if you download it
at least on iPhone I think it does
um I don't have a lot of push
notifications set up on my phone because
it'd just be bing bing bing bing bing
like a [__] pinball machine I hate my
phone anyways I don't answer a lot of
text I don't answer a lot of [__]
phone ask Gabe Sanchez Gabe do I answer
every [__] text like immediately
it would be help if your microphone was
on
see look I'm trying to get you a YouTube
subscribers you can't even turn on your
mindfulness oh my God uh no Tony leaves
me on red every day dude hey all day
sometimes all night long I'm like what
does he want yeah I know I'm just like
hey check out this meme
um and I'm like ah yes she he's two
hours behind me so a lot of times right
like because I stay up till you know one
o'clock in the morning sometimes
sometimes too so it's like midnight for
him but but he he thinks I'm up till one
or two his time right so he's like
and on the weekends sometimes like what
in the [__] is going on over here I'm
surprised that you don't have it on like
sleep mode oh something dude I I've
never had my phone off silent mode ever
oh what I well I mean like like I don't
have the noises on at all oh so they
don't know but I'm saying like you know
how you can put like do not disturb yeah
I mean I got it on do not disturb during
the show yes I don't want it buzzing
buzzing but
but that that's that's the only time I
have it because it buzzes and buzzes but
I you know I I'm I'm able to
um not be distracted by the vibrations
or the vibrator you know what I mean
okay Tracy's saying that
um patreon doesn't have notifications I
think it does yeah
because like so what because when I post
in uh let's say that I post something
from my patreon to my my subscribers
right it will say like it'll
automatically send it out and people who
are subscribed to my patreon can
probably confirm in the comments right
but also if I make a quick change like
oh [__] I want to change the title or
something oh yeah yeah
I'm like I know I don't want to notify
them again right like I don't have to
double because like I know they're
already getting notified right because
you're you're it's like a spelling error
that you're correct not like a time or
something right yeah I mean it was like
a time or something like that then you'd
want to notify right right or if or if
I'm adding an image like it's right
after the fact and I'm like oh there's
no way that people saw this you know
um so that's typically what I do like if
there is a change then I won't notify it
does sound kinky I mean if you want my
bells ringing and my phone vibrating
yeah yeah I don't know what described my
patreon I don't know what was
I don't know well it's because you said
vibrator oh yes yes yeah you forgot what
you said already man wow you know my
mind's in the gut in and out of the
gutter I mean look
yeah at least you're somewhere right
right I at least at least you're not in
a pile of [__] like the Republican party
right well or at least you're not a pile
of [__] I I mean I you know I'm
certainly in some people's eyes a pile
of [__] but you know what this pile of
[__] is gonna fight for democracy
whether he's a pile of [__] or not it's
something I'm gonna do it's just
something I mean and I might just do it
by saying geeky things on my show it is
my show so and are we back to non-porn
yeah we we set the counter back to zero
oh yeah yeah zero days last porn talk
since um kinky talk
hahaha
oh speaking of kinky talk you know
Tucker Carlson really had to use his
fake o face last night during this
interview he was like oh yeah you said
that oh oh I just splished in my pants
dude he did not want to be there no [__]
no he passionately hates that
[__] that's truly what he thinks
what he's texting his production I hate
him I I passionately hate him I hate him
passionately yeah whatever he's got a
great passion for hating Trump look I
called it on the show before which was
when the when the stuff was coming out
right and the different Publications
were going negative against Trump right
I was like dude we all know what's gonna
happen here they're gonna like cool it
off for a bit they're not gonna like
give him the the screen time or the air
time they're not gonna uh give him the
attention and then they're gonna come
back because it's all money right it's
all money to Rupert so Rupert's like hey
you gotta interview Trump first
interview since the arrest it's gonna be
[__] awesome and then it's gonna be
it was the same [__] that he always says
it was it it was a shot it was almost
verbatim to the Sean Hannity interview
in the sense that they're like we're
gonna we're gonna just volley this up
and we're gonna let you talk for as long
as you want and you're gonna use it as a
platform right we're not gonna question
you no follow-up questions oh yeah oh
you did that oh that's cool okay cool oh
yeah yeah uh I was I was listening last
night and I'm debating making a video
where I go it's a it's a 40 minute
interview but listen you watched it live
no no I I downloaded it I don't know
I I I couldn't hardly handle some of the
clips because I'm like this isn't new I
know they're different diaper there was
a part of me where I'm like ah do I
wanna watch this and then I was like it
could be funny to do a mashup of him
going
yeah you did sniffle a lot I don't know
how much Adderall he was on last night
but he was on a lot he was a sniffling
I'll just say that the interview the
interview definitely didn't pass the
sniff test uh but you know you know what
I think that is because I was talking to
someone
um
Mister here says PornHub please I need
to look back into that also what
happened
I don't know what I don't know what the
butt plugs but
um but anyway anyways uh speaking of
butt plugs
Donald Trump last night it felt like he
had something up his ass I mean or
here's here's because of the sniffling
like it was yeah yeah it was intense
last night but here's what I think it
actually is other than the Adderall and
all the [__] drugs all the drugs he's
done over the years to destroy his
sinuses here's what I think it is I
think he's doing breathing exercises to
keep the lunatic at Bay you know what I
mean like the ketchup lunatic oh like
there's a like a like a a like a Dr
Jackal Mr Hyde kind of right kind of
like the like the Hulk right but it's
not like a green Hulk it's like a red
fat sloppy Hulk that throws there there
is a red Hulk in the comics real I mean
he's not he's not like gross looking and
she's not like fat and sloppy no I mean
like he's like a Hulk right so like it's
just a different version of the Hulk
which actually will see and there's an
upcoming Marvel movie that we'll see
Harrison Ford who will play that role
and become the Red Hulk are you [__]
me I'm telling you the truth man God
damn yeah but no you're supposed to say
I wouldn't [__] you you're my favorite
turd I wouldn't [__] you you're my
favorite turd boom boom got him to say
it but yeah but somebody you know uh
Roderick says orange Hulk maybe there's
something there hey baby hey baby was it
wasn't the hamburger
uh what do you say wasn't the Hamburglar
kind of Orange
uh
uh yeah I think so let me see I mean
he's a criminal
he's a bandit and he loves Amber yeah
he's he's orange he's orange I mean here
let's uh
let me let me just pull this I'll give
you this you can pull it up and people
can can decide from yourselves right
like right is this don't let me tell you
what the [__] truth is I don't want
to ruin your good time all right so here
is um here's the no actually you know
who this looks like this looks like
[__] Eric Trump that's what this is
it's [__] Eric Trump
so he's the hamburglar's daddy yeah he
steals the burgers for Daddy Trump and
he's like he's like well that makes
sense anyway go give me a burger give me
a burger
from the red light and he's like okay
Dad I'm gonna go
burglars and burgers and then he goes
off and he does it just like that what
was that what was it how does Eric say
I'm just gonna go regular some burglars
or some some burglars and burgers wait
wait do it again do it again
I want to get it on a bigger screenshot
all right so Trump goes Eric I need a
burger go get me a burger Eric
I need a burger right now and then and
then Eric goes okay Daddy I'm gonna go
burglar some burgers okay
and that's what it is that's it that's
how it works that's how it works that's
how it works that's how the hamburger
came about or the orange Hulk whichever
maybe he's the orange Hulk and the and
yeah I'm sure he's like I'm sure if
somebody called in the orange yellow
could be like that sounds pretty amazing
Devin foggy if you're listening
make a movie
[Laughter]
oh my God how many movies do you think
will be made from the uh Trump trials oh
well there's definitely if I had to
imagine there's probably gonna be one of
those FX uh miniseries right like they
did with the OJ trial you know I think
we'll do one of those
um I think they'll make a they'll
probably make a Hallmark movie If I had
to imagine Hallmark will always they'll
always jump on that do you think
there'll be a ketchup shortage from the
movie that they'll have to use so much
ketchup well I think somebody somebody
if I if I don't know if I was writing a
script I might connect maybe the
Adderall shortage to the ketchup shorter
and see how there's a direct uh
correlation between the two right
um I can see that yeah yeah but I could
see I could see a few right Hallmark FX
uh maybe a Hulu uh uh
I'm trying to think so like there's
gonna be it's like the Dahmer effect
where there's several movies and then of
course you're gonna get the people on
the right so you might get a daily wire
one okay you'll definitely get you'll
you'll definitely get Trump's gonna be
all muscular and [__]
and the people in the courthouse you're
like oh I'm so sorry oh I can't believe
you're being arrested I'm so sorry
you'll always support you that's that's
the one thing that was new from this
interview okay I'll admit that that was
one thing that's new the new lie that he
tried out last night was that people
were sad that he was being arrested yeah
let's uh let's just let's just rethink
that one
um oh well I also one other person I
definitely think it's going to be Dinesh
D'Souza he's definitely gonna make oh
yeah he's definitely gonna make a movie
definitely but the also the other uh
somebody says how about Nick Nolte As
Trump well Nick Nolte that's a
possibility he could do it I think so
what's the one guy that played him in
the um the comer film oh what the hell
is that actor's name God damn it what
Comer film it was about and and and
Comey is what I mean Jim come James
Comey the movie The oh HBO yeah I think
yeah yeah that was uh that was the well
it was the Irish actor who played him
what's his name
wasn't he just nominee for an SQL yeah I
mean he's a really good actor he did a
good job playing trump it was it was a
decent me I don't know how [__] real
it was but I mean it was a good it was
uh Brendan Gleason that's it yeah yeah
that's it yeah that was that was I never
saw that one but yeah the other the
other thing that Trump tried out again
last night was the environmentalist
thing that he's an environmentalist oh I
heard that he's like
what the [__] are you [__] man he's like
you know there's actually two n-words
two Edwards about it and it's like dude
you gotta stop like right I don't know
I'm dancing around the n-word dude look
man we know the n word you really want
to say and uh right it's not nuclear
okay
[Music]
what did you say before that before I
brought back the the the Dinesh D'Souza
oh the LIE the new lie which you're
gonna play right now yeah yeah yeah
I'll tell you why it's a lie okay and
I'll tell you people were crying people
that worked there professionally work
there that have no problems putting in
murderers and they see everybody it's
tough tough place
and they were crying they were actually
crying they said I'm sorry uh they'd say
2024 sir 2024. and tears are pouring
down there is I've never seen anything
like the those people are phenomenal
those are your police yep those are the
people that work at the courthouse
they're unbelievable people uh many of
them were in tears or close to it
many apologies we're sorry sir we're
sorry [__] that [__] they were in now is
crying if anyone was into if anyone's in
tears it was a relax of joy and laughter
right okay listen when he walks out the
[__] door they didn't know the door
for him man
New York it's like it's like one of
those things when you when you're born
in New York it's just like a Birthright
you just hate Donald Trump right New
York City New Yorkers [__] hate
Donald Trump okay they cannot stand the
guy for years decades what he's done
since the 70s people in New York do not
like him and it's really not even have
to do with their political affiliation
no no
[__] dude
outside of the politics the things he's
done in the real estate market and how
he's treated people how he attacked the
Central Park five and still hasn't
apologized for it like the guy's a
grifting uh uh racist misogynist just
piece of [__] but
when he goes oh they were crying that no
they [__] weren't okay uh to your
point the the police the law enforcement
officers were like yeah [__] this and
they just let the door hit him they let
the door hit him show in the shoulder
she's like oh oh like I almost for a
moment I almost imagined you know like
the joke the running joke about soccer
players in terms of like when there's a
uh if there's like a uh
like somebody
will they'll like over exaggerate to get
together right
and you know you see videos all the time
where like there was never any contact
you were like three feet away right you
know you're just exaggerating for the
sake of getting this person getting
flagged right
I almost had a moment where that is what
Donald Trump was going to do he like
gets hit he's like ah ah somebody
assassinated me you know like that is a
door touch yeah we know what you know
what you know what I see with the door
and and it's you know I mean we could
evaluate the the door where no one held
the door for him for days probably yeah
but the reality of it is is that
normally those officers are escorting
people that will [__] hold the door
for themselves right like they're not so
[__] high in money
right that they would hold the door for
themselves or anyone else they would
hold the door so they weren't used to
some stupid [__] Silver Spoon little
[__] that was behind them that can't
hold the door for himself I mean it only
it only speaks to the problem that he
has not the problem they had do you
think that when he went through the
Iranian process like actual processing
he was just imagining like okay I'm in a
safe space
I'm in a safe space
fingerprint okay it's gonna be okay like
he's just he's just so he was just
fingerprinted right I think so I don't
we haven't got any confirmation that
yeah leading up to it it was he doesn't
what I'd read was he doesn't or didn't
need to take a photo now uh that seems a
little weird but it is what it is well
but I mean they there's I don't think
there's like New York state law of
exactly the process that they have to do
it's just law enforcement collecting you
know collecting the data on the person
that they're processing right so they
can identify this person because that's
all it is is identity I I mean
the biggest reason why is because back
in the old days we didn't have [__]
we didn't have ways to identify people
like uh DNA uh [__] digital records
off their cell phone you know signaling
where they're at location wise by by
cell towers I mean all that stuff is is
possibilities nowadays to identify where
a person's at or the identity of someone
but I've been I've been in a process
processing room and
um I don't know how this courthouse is
set up but generally when you go in a
processing room they have like they've
got a camera they got a spot where you
stand right because they want your
height right normally if they don't know
how tall you are that may be why they
took a mug shot them make him take his
shoes off to see a actually they're like
look uh many people have been wondering
you said you're 6'3 you said you're six
five you said like it I I'm I'm curious
right there's a part of me like I feel
like it's you should have a photo taken
but then again I don't know how right I
mean I don't understand why they
wouldn't take his photo why they
wouldn't why they wouldn't take his DNA
just like they do everyone else now the
theory goes is that the government
already has his DNA so they get a hold
of it but I mean he would fight it in
court so why not just take his [__]
DNA while he's standing there being
processed and he's under arrest right
and there's not a dick there's not a
goddamn thing you could do about it when
you're under arrest because when they're
processing you you are under arrest
you're [__] being detained right you
can't just like oh well I'm just gonna
leave now because you're trying to take
my DNA [__] I mean in most in a
lot of cases they'll take a urine
allowance a urine sample or some
something like that because in the
processing room that I was in there's a
big counter I mean it looked like a
almost looked like a doctor's office
really yeah without that without the bed
there was a big [__] machine that
took your fingerprints and the big
[__] and the big [__] camera and
[__] but there was a bathroom in there
where you had to give a [__] drug
sample or urine sample if you're on
drugs whatever I mean that's the [__]
that is typical and mostly yeah right
yeah but I'm not sure exactly what
because this probably would have been
embarrassing for him you know like he's
like oh I gotta I have to try to find it
you know little guy uh well they have to
watch you when you're doing right I know
so which is more embarrassing which is
like uh you know the where he's like the
only people that get to see my little
mushroom tip are the people that I pay
to marry me you know or the people that
I pay to not tell anyone that I had sex
with which is hilarious and I just want
to bring that up for just a quick moment
Donald Trump the only person who had to
pay like normally oh yeah man I had sex
with a porn star it was crazy like
people know sports or whatever
he might be the only person that I know
who was like no I don't want anyone to
know that I had sex with this porn star
nah no I don't like it because
because if he you know if he admitted to
it and he's like oh yeah you know I had
sex with Stormy Daniels whatever his
base would be like oh yeah [__] he had
he had sex with a porn star [__]
Alpha move Nick Adams be like oh [__]
like that's what they would all yeah but
they're the opposite now they're like oh
women gross like what right exactly
cooties right like what like oh she's
showing too much boobage like when did
you [__] stop liking half it's
like you know I asked this question on
Twitter last night like I legitimately
was curious but also like you know kind
of
you know rhetorical in a way which is
like uh you know do Republicans think
that the lgbtq plus Community just
popped up out of thin air like they just
appeared out of thin air like in the
same way that they're like oh my God all
these porn stars or this sexualization
this has been here for [__] years and
you never complained right I mean yeah
porn's a little weird now like I have to
admit sometimes I mean I'm just doing
I'm just doing research for the show
when I'm on porn that's all I'm trying
to do I'm just trying to see what stormy
is out there doing for the show that's
right I promise I promise no but
seriously there's some weird
there's a weird uh like subculture of
porn right I'll admit they're you know
look people are into some weird [__] man
you're porn sex whatever it is that's
your Kink as long as it's safe and
people are consenting right do your
thing right and you know there's nothing
safer than porn really I mean honestly I
mean it is yeah what you get tested
you're in a you're in a set well no I'm
saying when you're watching it right
like there's no you can't spread VD
around because you're jerking off the
porn right I don't know I'm sure that
some Pastor will tell you if you watch
porn you get herpes well like that I
know he's like that's how I got herpes
you know kind of thing and you're like
whoa dude how did you get that you know
yeah that's what that's what I feel like
it was from a dirty PornHub video yeah
like I watched this porn and I got this
sdd and it's like that's not exactly how
that works for home with Kurt Cameron is
that what's wrong with him it could be
you know I don't know I can't touch this
stuff I got all these STDs from have you
ever seen the movie that he did about
being addicted to porn is that the one
where he was he was yelling at the woman
against the wall like he was abusive I
don't I don't I don't I don't know that
part there's a movie it's called fire
fire some [__] where he's addicted to
porn he can't stop jacking off to porn
and yeah he can't stop jacking off the
phone
well it's a Christian it's a Christian
movie no I know but it's one of those
things where you're like hey so we're
gonna make a movie and you're like all
right what premise do we got and they're
literally Jesus God no no no no [__]
jerking off that's what it's gonna be
jerking off like a guy uh addicted to
masturbating a guy addicted to jerking
off okay so like what happens well he
jerks off in the office oh that's great
he jerks off in a car even better he
jerks off at his kids soccer game oh
that's the [__] money shot I'm trying
to remember the movie but I think most
the time you gotta remember this like I
don't know 15 years ago so he's he's
sitting in his living room at his desk
jerking off most of the time right and
he's he's on his that's that's what it
is uh Justin here on Twitch fireproof
that's what it's called fireproof
fireproof I knew it was fire something
fireproof
I don't watch
I I think I think um the reason why we
watched it it was years ago it had been
at least 12 13 14. oh it's a firefighter
movie
is he a firefighter I just remember Kirk
Cameron being and I just remember
Cameron being addicted to jerking off
that's all I remember like this is
[__] hilarious well the the plot line
is in an attempt to save his marriage a
firefighter uses a 40-day experiment
known as The Love Dare
wow wait is that what is that what oh
yeah yeah I'm literally on the IMDb
right now and I'm looking at him
from the creators of facing the giants
Kirk Cameron Aaron Bethy Bethea Bethy I
don't know giant spider behind do you
know do you know what face the Giants is
it's it's the really it's the really um
it's the really famous clip uh it's like
it's like a high school football team I
don't know if they're jerking off in
that movie I've never watched that movie
but the famous clip is I don't I don't
know I don't know if there's a lot of
jerking off and Kirk Cameron films it
seems like it from fireproof but maybe
there is no it's always [__] project
porn and porn and [__] jerking off
and Kirk Cameron films Christian
Christian films anyways so there's that
famous scene where the football player
the cow the high school football player
they blindfold them in the in the the
other player gets on his back and he has
to he has to Bear crawl 10 yards and the
coaches yelling at him and motivating
him and he crawls like a hundred yards
and he didn't even know it you know the
whole you've never seen that what what
hold on now I gotta I've seen you've
seen this glitch there's no way you
haven't seen this clip because it's like
you've seen the Giants oh it's like a
motivational clip facing the Giant's
Death Note Facing a Giant death crawl
scene yeah that's it
that's it hold on hold on hold on I'm
not playing it on here he's the coach
no well I mean there's an actor that
plays the coach that's in all the Kirk
Cameron movies because he can't get
anyone else acting as [__] weird
because they're all about jerking off I
mean who's I mean if it's everyone's
like wait this isn't porn I thought this
was porn there's seemed like a lot of
jerking off in the script for it not to
be porn I've never seen this I'm on
YouTube right now looking at this and
I've never seen a scene death crawl
scene from Facing the Giants incredible
motivation I I don't know no I've never
seen this shutdown [__] how much are you
are you kidding where do you watch these
movies what do you mean I haven't
watched that movie I've watched that she
has been on [__] social media I've
never I've never I've never seen when
was the film made does it show it 2008
yeah see since it's been God damn 2008
man you know how long ago that was [__]
me you know how long ago that was that
was just after Donald Trump had sex with
Stormy Daniels whoa whoa maybe there's
something to it I don't know maybe Kirk
Cameron knew someone says well about
Boogie Nights I don't think that's a
Kirk Cameron film but I know that's a
Mark Wahlberg no I I know that I'm just
gonna make a joke and you stepped up I'm
gonna say there's a lot of jerking off
in that film but I don't know that it's
a great camera maybe maybe Kirk Cameron
made a movie called booby nights boobie
nights and it's like oh no like he goes
out at night and just a bunch of boobs
show up he's like oh God no no the
Temptation no no the boobs you know
maybe that's what he does how did we get
here I I don't know how we got it uh we
got here from Kirk Cameron if we Trek
back we go uh oh yeah porn stars porn
stars
porn stars
show the interview again yeah well you
know I'm trying I'm trying here so this
is this is the n-word part
um I'm just gonna [__] the transition
just go straight to the n-word I I
didn't I'm not I'm not saying he said he
says there's two he's there's two
n-words apparently let's listen to his
explanation of
the N word I call it the n-word
you have two n-words you don't mention
either one of them
okay okay
there's only really I mean one inward
okay let's face it right like when you
say that in mordino like and I I I don't
know what he's trying to do like is he
trying to redefine what in word means so
maybe so he's so that way yeah maybe so
his proud boys can like stand back and
stand by and say the n-word safely and
proudly you know behind a little bit I
get it I don't get the I don't get why
he's trying to Rebrand new coins well I
also wonder I also wonder if somebody
himself or someone else in his little uh
little cohort said hey you know what
will drive the virality of these
interviews or these videos that you do
is if you talk about this thing called
the n-word right you say the N word oh
it shows like say the N word it's like a
it's like a click bait [__] yeah yeah
you're saying there are two n-words I'd
be like whoa what kind of what do you
say now Donald Trump's talking about the
n-word you got you got the racists who
are like uh uh-huh and then you got the
People Like Us watching like whoa
finally he said it so so I guess
supporters like finally he said it and
everyone else like ah finally he [__]
said it out loud yeah because we know he
said it come on yeah oh and I'm not
talking about it there's even not the N
word I'm talking about right I mean like
we know I mean like one we know that
Donald Trump has said the n-word
multiple times but there's also the
accounts from people who have worked on
The Apprentice who are like yeah he said
the n-word on the [__] set right well
there's some that say
that uh um
oh the creator Mark um God damn it his
name like a showrunner yeah the No No
the [__] the show the producer of the
show Apprentice oh yeah
um God damn his name excuse me chat yep
Mark Vernon
um there's some says that that they know
he has hot mic recordings of trump
saying it yeah like there's no way they
don't have hot mics like there's I just
I just wonder why there's two things in
my mind one I'm like hey why hasn't that
thing come out yet right and the other
one is like even if it did come out
would anyone stop liking him I'm sure
that people who are who are oh there
there would be more people that's I
think that's why he's saying it right
because like he's saying inward like
that's that that's the that's the thing
they like right
he's saying the n word right right even
though it means nuclear we know what
he's saying you know it's a stupid [__]
that stupid frat boy locker room [__]
you know what I mean to grab and buy the
[__] where you're joking about
assaulting women and all kinds of crazy
[__] and it's the same [__] it's the
same [__] you you've been in a boy's
locker room with a bunch of [__]
white dudes that thought they'd get away
with anyone anything you know and now
and now Trump's doing this he's doing
this interview after he was arrested you
know uh
and essentially he got grabbed by well
by a [__] right right right and they
they they definitely made him uh his
[__]
um and I'd love to play some more of
this is there any specific one you want
me to play because most of it's just the
same old [__] uh go to the one that
Tucker outside yes that's the great one
yeah because it's it's it's it's kind of
weird actually I'm like why did he do
that outside what right could he not
wait to get away from that [__]
well he he said that he said that he was
because I was watching the actual uh the
actual interview and they said he was a
cross
the whatever body of water that is
that's right so this is he's in Palm
Beach right right and you'll see that
he's outside obviously because of the
background but they didn't there's no
windshield or anything for him yeah they
just let him outside like that I mean
like at the end at the end of the
interview uh was he outside live is that
what that was was the live show well
whatever here's the shot yeah I think I
think it was live it says live I mean it
what oh you know what it is live so
which means he had to stay there for a
[__] hour outside
because what ended up ended up happening
was well better to be inside with that
[__] with the [__] hamburger what
ended up happening was the reason he
well so he's outside because at the very
end of the interview he's talking with
Sean Hannity to hand it off for Sean
Hannity segment and then Sean Hannity's
like I kind of like you out there you
know out there and then even Tucker is
like oh my wig you know it makes a joke
obviously because that's the joke that a
lot of people say about him is that he's
got this way gun that Tucker Carlson
wears a hairpiece yeah right oh I'm I'm
way more worried about [__] Tucker's
vile words that come out of his oh no
100 but he was out there the whole time
for I mean like I'm sure maybe he went
into the van and then went outside but
the fact that they had to do it outside
on some Pier or dock somewhere in the
Mar-A-Lago Palm Beach area and it's dark
so you can't see anything behind you
it's not like there's a great it looks
like a [__] boat dock right like look
at the back you got to pull I think that
looks like it it looks like he's
standing out there and he has to be
there at every Point like he couldn't go
into the studio right they're like oh we
finished the interview it was like right
away and we didn't have time to fly back
like we couldn't find a location or a
room in [__] Mar-A-Lago where they
could set up a green screen and a camera
and some lights are you [__] me yeah
my guess is my guess is is that is that
he didn't want to be in Mar-A-Lago to
broadcast from marlago so you wanted to
broadcast from Palm Beach but this is
the this is eight seconds long so here's
the here's the clip that you wanted uh
here you go for a man who was
caricatured as an extremist we think
you'll find what he has to say moderate
sensible and wise
for many
who has ever described Donald Trump as
as those three things right the [__]
as soon as as soon as he said that I
heard this in the back
this is the guy who passionately hates
Donald Trump yeah like I wonder if we
panned over if it was just Rupert
Murdoch holding a gun he's like
say the [__] that's on the teleprompter
right read the teleprompter [__]
because he had what he had to do is he
was there the full hour because he had
to intro each segment when they came
back from commercial break wait wait so
so how many how many breaks do they put
in between this interview you said
there's 40 minutes it's 40 minutes I
mean 20 minutes of commercials right
right so it was a full episode there was
nothing else that was offered inside
that episode oh [__] is that the same
way Hannity was so he got two full
episodes he got two full episodes from
what I remember because they let the guy
talk so much and then they're like oh
yeah
that's so nice I believe everything you
say you know and then he's texting his
producer I hate this [__] yeah
this guy's a [__] liar I can't
believe people believe this stupid [__]
I can't believe our viewers are this
[__] dumb you know it is insane here
let me look at the you know there's
there's an update speaking of Fox News
and those text messages there's an
update in the Fox News
um
um their legal problems have you seen
this so there's a shareholder at Fox at
assuming Rupert Murdoch and I think four
um
uh board members okay and the reason why
is because they they're claiming their
shareholders claiming that they
knowingly let this happen which is
causing these lawsuits from dominion and
I mean that sounds like a pretty good
lawsuit if I was a sheriff turns on you
Jesus Christ see I I actually
um three months ago I believe that this
that this Dominion thing that boxing is
going to write Dominion to check smart
man I can check this is going to go away
right and Rupert Murdoch was going to be
down probably billions of dollars but it
wasn't going to phase him right right
we're gonna phase him really that much
and Fox News that much because of the
contracts that they have structured for
the money that they make because it's
all in Fox news's favor not not in these
the the places where they air Fox News
it's in Fox news's favorite but because
they get they get a share of the
subscription service not just the
advertising dollars yeah um but anyways
that's how they make a shitload of money
um but anyways the the thing the thing
that is is flooring me here is that
Dimension smart manager like no we're
not going to settle [__] this [__] yeah
why would you all the way we're going to
bury this deep down inside they got him
they got him in the ringer right now
like every time they try to push this
and say hey we shouldn't be sued because
there's no justification for for it the
judge or the you know the the person
who's looking over the case is like uh
nope you can't be trusted you lied you
you knowingly did it
um and there's no reason to which we
should allow you to get out of this
right which is funny to see that not
only is it another company coming after
them for saying like oh you lied about
this stuff but now knowing that it's uh
it's a shareholder right it's an actual
uh person who who supports at one point
supported the company enough that they
were going to buy stock in it right so
they're suing Rupert Murdoch
um his son
uh some directors at Fox Corp and
apparently in four looks like four um
I believe it's four board members and
and it's probably because those board
members actually had some sort of say
over content probably and there's
probably some sort of evidence somewhere
that these board members were
communicating hey stop doing this [__]
and like nah nah okay well it's good for
Ratings because the fact of the matter
is
um and Reuters has it here here's uh
Rachel bittick offers uh tweet on it
with the Reuters article I'll tweet that
so everyone can see
um the fact remains is the reason why
Fox News was doing this really is for
profit Fox News wasn't doing this yeah I
mean I think this guy's a [__]
scumbag right yeah he's a fascist but
this guy daily motivation isn't to
destroy our democracy I know that sounds
great and it's great you know and maybe
I'll change my mind over time just
because I want to say it out loud on the
show to get people around up but really
the only thing that motivates this
[__] piece of sludge right here is
[__] money oh yeah I mean he said
it's not red it's not blue it's green
right right like that's in the Dominion
docks of him saying he's like he doesn't
care about this [__] right for the same
reason he's like yeah man I'm gonna [__]
on Trump because it's gonna drive sales
that's right I support Trump because
it's going to drive sales that's right
oh it's the first interview Tucker you
gotta do it because people are going to
talk about the fact that you [__]
hate this guy and you're the one doing
the interview exactly
I mean it's the fact that he I mean he
doesn't care about anyone who works the
company he's like look at the at the end
of the day I'm I'm concerned with the
bottom line and I want more money I'm
I'm a [__] I don't even know how old
what is it 80 90 like how old is [__]
Rupert Murdoch thousand years old the
guy looks like I saw this is a picture
this is a 30 year old picture of him by
the way I saw him I said I saw a photo
of him in the ocean that [__] water
looked like it was gonna sweep him away
okay he was like the poor the poor sea
animals you know or sea animals and also
his he was just engaged and they just uh
they just ended that engagement which is
funny which oh it's weird but well so 92
92 is what people say Rachel's um saying
here it's it's Rupert Murdoch and four
other board members which is probably
including his son yeah which would be my
guess I wonder if Paul Ryan's wrapped up
in this you know Paul Ryan
yeah hates [__] drunk but he is a
board member he is a board member yes I
don't know if he's named which is funny
because I haven't read the article yeah
but here's the Reuters article people
want to read it and go you can go um
tweet here and also follow
um Dr Rachel bittickoff or while you're
but the other thing too is when you
remember that that Paul Ryan has on
multiple occasions on on TV on
interviews in in uh in talks that he's
done little Fireside Chats whatever he's
like look we're tired of losing Donald
Trump lost Us in 2018 2020 and 2022.
we're not going to back the guy or
rather he's a loser
and then you know do the same to the
same effect of all these other
Republicans in the same way that rumor
Murdoch Works he's like well I'm not
gonna totally
like toss him aside because if he
becomes a nominee which he will become
then I'm gotta back him so I can't say
anything bad about him right now but I
can
I can say that he's a loser and I can
talk [__] about him I can use my
newspaper my network to uh to talk bad
about him but I can also use my network
to support him right so I feel like you
know Paul Ryan for as much as he's
trying to like reinvent himself you know
like every other Republican does after
they leave some you know some position
they've been in
you know you have to remember that yeah
that at the end of the day it's the the
incentivizing factor is the fact that he
is a board member so he's going to do
what's best for the company to grow
which is I'm going to talk bad about
Trump I'm going to talk good about Trump
right which Paul Ryan has came out and
on other networks right right in fact
but he won't say no he'll say he's a
loser but he won't say no to voting for
him or supporting him right he's like
well I'll support the nominee well if he
becomes a normally he's like I'll
support the nominee everyone Bill Barr
did the same [__] they all like skirt
around and don't answer the question and
explicitly say no I will not support
Donald Trump because he's a [__]
loser they'll say he's a [__] loser
but I'll support the nominee you know
who else is being sued
in federal court uh does his name well
depends on what what how you want to
spell it it's a g or a j well right it's
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan is
Young sued in federal court uh Alvin
Bragg is sick and tired of Jim Jordan's
obstruction and not not only Jim Jordan
but he's the lead person on this on this
lawsuit right you see his name right
here on the actual uh southern district
of New York
um and what Alvin Bragg is going to do
is get a judge to put an end to this
[__]
stupid ass Twitter battle that yeah Jim
Jordan's trying to have with Alan Bragg
on the Judiciary
um committee's [__] official Twitter
did he get can can a judge order a gag
order
on Jim Jordan to be like dude well I
mean I mean
a judge can say your subpoena is invalid
it's not right right right and I just I
just wonder if if I have to appeal it
right I'm sure they will but but here's
I I think here's the main key point that
that I want people to remember here is
that this idea that Alvin Bragg somehow
is bringing flimsy charges and this is
all [__] political and it's all but
listen
if it if if it is political what is Jim
Jordan and these politicians scared of
what are you scared of right and who is
directing you and what communication
have you had with the defendant about
what what subpoenas you're issuing
on his criminal case I mean it's gonna
be a simple argument in front of a judge
and here's gonna be here's gonna be
because Alvin Bragg is hired a law firm
this is not Alvin Bragg's team bringing
this lawsuit there there New York has
happened to spend their money
because Jim Jordan is spending federal
dollars to try to obstruct in this
criminal investigation I want you to
know that this is all big government big
Republican government [__] here that's
all this is because what Alvin Bragg's
main argument is going to be is hey it's
against New York state law for me to do
what he wants me to do I can't do it I
can't it's against the law so the
federal judge is going to say well
states rights right like I mean when did
these Republicans Stop Believing in
state sovereignty when it's just it's
another moment where Republicans are
like oh man [__] that thing that we said
to own the libs came back to bite Us in
the ass right and that's what's
happening here and there's also a a clip
I just sent you of Luna
of Anna Anna Anna Paulina Luna who you
know is a republican in the Florida
congresswoman is she on the Judiciary
Committee
uh I think she is or on this I think
she's on the subcommittee of
weaponization yeah yeah yeah because she
was speaking before so I think she is
right now she's she is brand new to
Congress she's a freshman right yeah I
believe so
um she was an at Trump big Trump
supporter and actually kind of like a
Marjorie Taylor green type I wonder if
they got her off a talent website like
they did Lauren bobert I don't know
just a good day these are questions that
we should be asking don't you think we
should know where they found these
candidates
shouldn't we know as Americans what
these candidates qualifications were to
hold a seat in Congress I don't know I'm
just asking questions right okay let's
let's see what Anna Anna Paul Elena Luna
has to say here I'm sure it's [__]
batshit crazy but let's listen and so
the fact that they are doing this to try
to hide information the one thing I
learned Martha is whenever you do
something and someone immediately has a
knee-jerk reaction to hide things um
it's because they're guilty and I very
much so look forward to helping wait
representative Jordan as well as the
other members of house Judiciary
uncovering this does she know does she
know that Jim I don't report sex crime
Jordan is still defying a subpoena does
she know that yeah
[Music]
it's like 300 and something days I think
now oh my God what up it's dude it's it
is do they think we're not paying
attention it's uh it's well I think I
think that they I think that they think
that their viewers and their base
definitely yeah right I mean we have to
remember
of everything you know of everything
that they've done so far right Donald
Trump I mean like look if it's funny
that she would go I mean you couldn't
honestly write a better line to be like
hey you just described the Republican
party you just described Trump right
here like if you have a knee-jerk
reaction it means you're trying to hide
something right what do you call the
post that [__] trumped it on true
social or or the obstruction of of
[__] Nara and the FBI to get back the
[__] government
what about well Jim Jordan was asked how
many times he talked to Trump on January
6 and he's like oh well I had to I don't
know I'm gonna have to uh you know it's
uh you know can we talk about something
else like oh hey you know what we talk
about Scott Perry trying to make sure
that the doj doesn't get inside his cell
phone there's another one oh you know
what else in Georgia there was over 12
people who were trying to defy a
subpoena you know who else is trying to
defy a subpoena Mike Pence and then he
was like you know what I'm not gonna
appeal this and then Donald Trump's like
you goddamn right you're gonna appeal it
yeah so what are you talking about you
[__] me jerk the knee-jerk reaction
right of responding to be like uh it
means they're gonna hide something yeah
I totally agree it means you're trying
to hide something but Alvin Bragg saying
hey I'm gonna sue you because you're
trying to interfere and you're you know
you're causing harm to my investigation
intentionally causing this interference
and harm uh uh this constitutional
attack
uh it it's it's it's it's crazy that she
would go on and be like oh it's them
doing dude the projection is Rich right
well it's always it's always with these
[__]
here's the thing is that Alvin Bragg the
reason why the Manhattan D.A isn't
divulging certain information about the
grand juries because it's [__]
illegal yeah he can't do it he has to
keep it under seal also like why it's
under seal you yeah [__] dummies and
if you have to remember like okay we're
not going to you know the the first time
we would ever actually see this trial
start or I guess them coming back to the
court is in December and it probably
will get pushed right they're gonna try
to delay on Trump's side you know it's
just one of those things that's gonna
happen the guy loves to delay right and
so when you look at this there's a
reason why you wouldn't publicly go out
and say oh you know what uh I'm gonna
talk about the grand jury I'm gonna talk
about what our whole case is like why
would you that was that's the dumbest
thing ever like you have to be the
dumbest lawyer and that's not to say
that Donald Trump's lawyers haven't done
something like this but you have to be
the dumbest [__] lawyer to go out and
say hey everyone here's all the
documents here's all the evidence the
proof everything that is going to
bolster our argument as to why Donald
Trump is a criminal and why we're
charging him with 34 felony counts of
falsifying business records you know
obviously with implying that there's a
conspiracy to be had here
you have to be the dumbest [__]
lawyer to ever think oh you know what I
should totally show my hand for everyone
to see like why would why do Republicans
think that's the way to go because of
course when the when the tables are
turned they'd be like oh well I don't
have to show you [__] I don't got to
tell you anything but but it's only be
it's only to obstruct and to own the
libs uh Rick here on Facebook says read
Joseph gerbil's writings what does
Stephen Miller have to do with this
right
I'm sorry sorry you know what's funny
about Stephen Miller and Joseph gerbils
yeah
Stephen Miller had to testify in front
of Jack Smith's grand jury speaking of
grand juries and he did oh [__] did you
see the news that came out about Stephen
Miller no go ahead
while I'm moving to a different
politician um yeah pull up the Stephen
Miller stuff did you know did you know
that there is a um a new uh sort of not
really I mean he wants to he's not
really gonna he's thinking see he wants
to go to Iowa but he he wants to run for
president
it's Tim Scott have you heard this he's
opening up an exploratory committee he's
not running I gotta love that oh there's
gonna listen I bet there's gonna be
dozens of these where they're like oh
I'm opening up an exploratory committee
to see if I want to run against Trump
because someone needs to be the leader
not not that guy even though he's going
to be the nominee I think this is so
dumb watch this video this is really
stupid
I Will Never Back Down a defense of the
conservative values that make America
exceptional and that's why exceptional
is it exceptional because you support
the guy that says make America great
again again and again and again yeah
yeah so which is it is it exceptional or
is it not which is it I I I don't know I
mean like whenever you ask like hey when
was America when was the last time
America was great and then like well you
know it's uh well and you know they
can't say why because they can't say it
out loud because it's going to be one of
those n-words you know right when
America was great at the time when I
could say one of those two
well I mean that's that's that's the
that's the main thing here right is that
this is all for show this uh vivec guy
we've listened to him and we I think
we've been in spaces with this guy he's
running he doesn't know a goddamn thing
he's the dumbest sack of [__] I've ever
heard of running for prison it's
hilarious watching him talk he had no
idea that that John Edwards was John
Kerry's running mate and John Edwards
was [__] indicted on Election Finance
[__] fraud he had no clue no clue I
mean we're talking [__] less than 20
[__] years and be back doesn't know
that [__] what a dumb son of a [__]
listen all this [__] with Nikki Haley
answer Hutchinson and I said Assa Assa
Hutchinson Tim Scott
um we're gonna have Larry Hogan I don't
think Rhonda Santos is getting in his
window is completely closed at this
point yeah
um all these all this [__] [__]
um here's what I think Mike Pence give
me a [__] break this is all [__]
this is all the show that Donald Trump
had competition all we had we he had
competent but he he rose above the
Coptic he's not a loser Heroes above the
competition yeah [__] did he rise above
the competition or did the shittiest
piece of scum just float right well it
could be because I mean like look you
know you know when you when you know
when you're like in a like hot tubs
they've got like that you know it's like
a bunch of you know dead skin and
bacteria and stuff it just builds up on
you know in a hot tub that nobody cleans
like and it starts bubbling up skim on
the pudding yeah yeah or like when you
when you're in the ocean right and
there's like that that foam that comes
up like that's the type of [__] you're
like hey that's the Republican that's
the [__] party and then there's like
that little there's that little speck of
[__] that that just is able to sit on
top of the foam you know that's Donald
Trump it's like oh he just kind of just
landed and didn't sink
uh everyone else here is is gross
um but anyway uh yeah so somebody said
go back to Stephen Miller yeah well
we're gonna get to it here yeah I'm
trying to figure out what this is
because this has to do with um Stephen
Miller is the president of a group
called America First legal which he was
the he's the origin God damn man he's
patient can you he's patient zero he's
patient zero zero he's patient zero when
it comes to uh uh the the news that came
out about Donald Trump his home being
raided here's gerbils I mean Stephen
Miller yeah yeah he even looks like
gerbils have you ever noticed that he's
he definitely looks like a dick
story about the first legal because up
and they're claiming that Joe Biden
ordered the basically is what they're
right so basically the theory or the the
conspiracy theory that was created by
Stephen Miller all right so he created
this legal organization that was not
real right which is he a warrior
um I don't believe so is he a lawyer is
he does he a license I mean he won't be
long If he if he is now he's even if I
look him up right now where did he go
he's Santa Monica is where he lived uh
University he's from that woke ass state
California yeah he's he's about 30 45
minutes mother woker uh
he went to no well he's well the closest
thing is Miller is on the Southern
Poverty laws Center for a list of
extremists oh well
um he's the Nazi he's a Nazi there's
that there's no you know I I I do not
see anything in here about him being a
lawyer you know this this smells of like
uh Tom Fenton type [__] where they're
pretending to be lawyers you know what I
mean where they caught America First
legal wink yeah like we're a bunch of
lawyers that don't know anything because
we're not actually lawyers right so
what's the story here they've invented
this story so he might even has ordered
the raid right so he made up this
organization right he was like I got
this organization you know America First
legal right of course America First
legal yeah I mean that's a [__]
driving traffic term right there SEO
going for it so
he makes this fake organization and then
they start tweeting out back in uh I
forget when this is but basically they
they started tweeting out that oh there
was a threat right there's a thread of
Records obtained from an organization
into the circumstances surrounding the
Mar-A-Lago raid for further confirm that
the FBI obtained access to these records
through a special access request from
the Biden White House on behalf of the
doj so they made this whole story up
about how Biden was the driving force to
investigating Trump
and then they said so what is a special
access request because this isn't an
order a special access request is not an
order from the White House to have an
agency do something this is a request
from an agency of what and how they can
handle this information is that correct
yeah because basically what is it's it's
a security protocol when you're trying
to provide highly classified documents
you have safeguards right so you're
requesting this and that's what they're
talking about so they're like that that
it's you know you're requesting certain
information on behalf of an individual
and so they're saying Biden is White
House right specifically explicitly
asked made this request
to to have this done to look into Donald
Trump right to for these documents and
what you find out is that people like
Jenna Ellis uh who else uh Dinesh
D'Souza uh Lauren bobert uh the Gateway
pundit like all of these people were
were pushing this idea unfounded totally
debunked conspiracy theory that the
Biden administration had set up Trump by
using the FBI they're saying that the
White House directly coordinated with
the FBI to set Trump up right that was
what they were pushing they're like oh
this is a big setup it's a whole it's a
thing you know which again you mean like
Trump tried to use the IRS against
Andrew McCain right right right exactly
but also it's the it's the idea that
they were saying oh well because it
totally just goes against the [__]
hundreds of theories they came up with
Donald Trump saying oh it's a hoax they
planted it I took it it's real it's
amazing if I want to right did you put
it there did you put it there or did you
take it you you clearly confirmed that
you spoke to these people and now you're
saying that they planted it after the
fact you're saying that they showed up
on August 8th they're like oopsies and
then dropped it around why I mean when
they when manga forms their stories they
have to have both sides of the fence and
the reason why is because it's all wise
so they gotta have they gotta pick out
all the lies right it's all got to be
the lies so basically so so basically to
kind of summarize this is you had them
push out this Theory right they're like
oh we got a check mark we're America
First legal we're a Legal Foundation
we're our organization we're telling you
right now that this is what happened
Biden even Jordan even Jim Jordan from
the house Judiciary Community was
originating wow wow wow like like
[__] wow he paid attention more to
that tweet than he did to his students
getting sexually and then you had I mean
this is it's honestly like I'm trying to
think of like how the best way to
describe it's like you're laundering
fake news through real news organization
well no I don't say real I don't say
real I mean this is how this is how
information yeah this is how this is how
you this is how you launder fake news
right you cycle it through a bunch of
different people and then you get a
bunch of normal people who are linking
out to these places and saying oh look
uh this is what happened it's in this
article it's in this article it's all
the same stuff it's like when you send
out a PR newswire it's it's a template
and you're like hey this company is
announcing this product being launched
they send it out to the pr newswire like
three in the morning and then people can
use that as a template to be like oh
look this company XYZ is adding this
feature or they're releasing this
product or whatever it is right as like
as information that would be uh that
would complement whatever article you're
writing about that company that's what
it is and so this is what happened here
is uh for America First legal was using
themselves as a way to uh you know
disseminate this fake news and launder
it out through a bunch of people Jenna
Ellis Lauren bober Jim Jim Jordan
through the house Edition committee Fox
News Eric Trump was doing Eric Trump
like all these people especially Eric
Trump is like I've watched the video
tape I watched the video Eric Trump who
by the way said he watched the videotape
he's like I watch the videotape and it
shows so much of and we should release
it Sean is like yeah you should release
he goes oh we we will release it we're
going to release it they've never
released it because the reason why it's
because the reason why is the doj
doesn't want the Marisa and the reason
why is because doj wants to use it
against him in court yeah that's why
that's that's why the Trump family is
having such a hard time to release that
tape they'd love to release it so they
can [__] edit it and spin it up and
right just like they did the [__]
stupid Talent boxes that they did 2 000
mules if they do again for the same
reason that uh Alvin and Bragg's like no
I'm not gonna show you guys what I'm
gonna do like I'm not gonna show you my
def my my prosecution strategy here
that'd be the dumbest [__] thing in
the same way that Jack Smith and geoj's
like yeah we're not gonna show you the
stuff that we're not gonna give you the
stuff that you can manipulate I mean it
could be said that they manipulate it
and then Jack Smith and the doj come
after and say okay well you then
used this to intentionally lie further
about this conspiracy you had to to
steal classified documents right because
what what they're actually saying what
what what the fake organization the fake
legal what looks like a wall yeah
organization legal right because it has
that word in it what they're actually
doing here is because yes there has to
be a request sometimes for this
information but it appears that that
request was asked by the doj which
technically is the Biden Administration
right because doj is part of the
executive branch which is part of the
Biden administration at this point so
obviously the White House is over the
the Department of Justice and and and
Donald Trump's raid so Joe Biden is the
head of the White House I mean he sits
in the walls so obviously obviously Joe
Biden's sitting around trying to figure
out how to get Donald Trump arrested I
mean yeah yeah even though even though
that even though that is true none of
that is true even though that Joe Biden
kept people in the doj who were they're
like oh we're doing investigation to
Hunter Biden okay you can stay because
if I if I meddle with this it's gonna
look real bad right
so it's just one of those things and
even kept Durham he even kept Durham he
was still [__] trying to investigate
Hillary Clinton they all thought oh this
is gonna be the [__] Smoking Gun and
Durham kept losing and it was him boy he
lost twice in court yeah in front of a
jury I wonder I wonder uh Alvin Bragg is
one for he's 1-0 on juries I wonder how
many juries he's going to be undefeated
on and how many Jack Smith and finding
Willis is going to be I don't I mean I
think if you you know if this if this
was a boxing match you know it's one of
those things where you're like oh every
round went to the people that were
Prosecuting right like Trump tried to do
it and he's like just like kept getting
hit in the face and they're like oh well
we gotta we got a team
knocked out but we're going on a
technicality here right I think I think
it's
all the way back around to Jim Jordan
again right yeah because Jim Jordan was
one of the ones that that was a
trafficker in this misinformation this
[__] and they knew it was [__]
yeah right through through the official
surprise are you surprised by a guy who
said okay Elon Trump and it was like for
two months it was like I don't see that
tweet I didn't tweet that well look and
then deleted it look what they tweeted
look what he tweeted this morning he's
mad he's mad that NPR is the dumbest
[__] ever and how do people keep saying
this [__] do they not understand that
only one to two percent of the budget
comes from government grants well okay
if you're looking for logic in these
people's dumb [__] then you're gonna
be looking up here's the thing here's
what happened NPR put a press release
out today saying we are not gonna post
anything on Twitter anymore because we
can't trust it one of the reasons why is
it's come to light that Elon is not only
letting uh accounts that have the n-word
in the handle not nuclear the actual
inward in the handle he's verifying them
he's letting them be terrified
which is an excuse for any company out
there to not be on Twitter or posting
any tweets at all like that reason alone
if that you could have an account that
has that
were people making accounts with the
n-word in there as parody accounts of
NPR no no I'm just I'm just saying NPR
is looking at Twitter and go look that
we're not going to participate
this is crazy well and and I think part
of their to paraphrase part of NPR's
press release was this doesn't benefit
us at all we don't get we don't get
anything from tweeting anyways so we're
definitely not going to Tweet and
participate in this dumpster fire right
it's basically because honestly like as
someone who has a podcast who has
influence on the internet if you want to
call that
and like we tweet a lot but we it you
know how difficult it is even with
Twitter as it's designed to post links
to get them to different platforms you
don't get that many like a lot of people
go on on the on the Twitter broadcast of
this show and they're like oh you only
got five viewers I'm like yeah it's
[__] Twitter dummy yeah the the
[__] Periscope uh tool is broken the
only reason why I do it is because I
post the YouTube link and we get off my
two post on the show a day like to be
transparent about it because I post an
announcement and then I post the actual
broadcast on Twitter between those two
we get about 200 250 link clicks every
day now that doesn't necessarily mean
they're clicking the YouTube link right
it's more than likely that's what it is
but that's the only reason why I still
do it because I feel like it's worth if
if more than 100 people are going there
to find the link to the show then it's
worth me posting it so they can get here
to the YouTube right or twitch or
whatever because they have two links
I've got my website and the YouTube link
specifically for that show on those
posts I don't post it there for people
to watch on Twitter it is the shittiest
experience to watch any [__] live
content on Twitter it's horrible if
you're commenting they can't see it no
one's there to moderate it it's horrible
it's [__] garbage yeah because
Twitter's garbage yeah and that's why
MPR doesn't want to participate because
not only is the platform [__] they
Twitter does not have a a very good
broadcasting
um strategy with like periscope and MPR
is a um what are they they're um what
what's MPR stand for what does it stand
for
um I don't know it's almost like the P
stands for something right I feel like
the P the p is really important there
right like right yes
it's almost like the end like it's not
it's like it's not that type of N word
and then radio maybe nuclear public no
right national public radio radio like
they're a Broadcasting Company yeah yeah
so they so the platforms that they want
to participate on anyways likely are the
ones that you can broadcast from right
like I'm on Mastodon but I really don't
like it and the reason why is because I
can't broadcast over there I can't I
can't it's very limited it's an
alternative but I I it's also the other
problem I have with it too is like oh
[__] I gotta post it on like I have to
actively remember to add that to like oh
I gotta share that and I don't do it
like I should I post the show
announcement over there and that's it
and the reason why is because I can't
broadcast over there we are I'm a
broadcaster I broadcast the show every
[__] day if I can't broadcast
something on your platform I'm probably
not going to [__] with it yeah it's just
probably not going to happen so that's
like Discord discord's a [__] to get
this broadcast in Discord you gotta do a
bunch of fancy [__] so I don't do it
[__] that [__] yeah and same thing as
PornHub if I could easily broadcast to
PornHub just with a click of a button
I'd broadcast over there and I'd start
posting on PornHub that's right I post
my nudes I'm no I'm just kidding maybe I
don't know if you guys want them
um but here's the thing NPR said we're
not gonna be on Twitter anymore
Jim Jordan from The House judiciaries
official Twitter account calls to defund
NPR which Gabe pointed out wouldn't even
affect NPR at all like it's so
ridiculous and we've heard this before
they did it they did it okay here to
give you to give you an idea a few years
ago uh before 2020
uh because during 2020 they were like ah
defund NPR okay now I think it was like
2018 or 2017 or something like that uh
NPR started tweeting out a bunch of
these tweets on on January 4 or on July
4th right they're tweeting things out
just boom tweet here's a tweet here's a
tweet
and
a bunch of people on the right a bunch
of Republicans got all [__] up in
arms and upset and they're like oh my
God can you can you uh
can you see this they're they're they're
pushing their propaganda as a tyrannical
government do you want to know what they
were posting on July 4th what
the Declaration of Independence what
that sounds horrible right that that
that sounds demonic was it in red is
that yeah it was it was a time it was It
Was Written in Blood they were taking
photos they were sending out but it's
just like the fact that you know even
these Patriots are like oh my God can
you imagine the you guys talk about how
you love the Constitution and this and
that but only to realize that the things
that's being posted are the [__]
Patriot the most patriotic documents
that we've had in this country supposed
to be yeah supposed to be right and
these people are like I'm a patriot
initiative they're like tyranny and
you're like wait but this is a document
that you supposedly would support so
what the [__] you talking about it just
shows you that nobody knows anything
it's the same reason why they're all
like oh my God Bud Light Coors Light
it's all [__] gay it's been gay for
years guys
for a year since like 1978 cores has
been so [__] gay they've been flying
that flag they're the gayest [__]
beer there is
Denver for crying out loud isn't Denver
isn't Denver like in the top five gay
cities in the United States I think it
might be I might be it might be uh I'm
serious they because they've had a pride
parade there for like 50 years and
that's something else all these people
there was uh I've uh I think I'm trying
to remember what state but I just saw
like a mashup oh it was in Tennessee I
think it was in Tennessee and they were
talking about how they didn't want the
pride parade or they didn't want a a
pride event happening in this open Park
all of this [__] has been happening for
years right this isn't new and the Merit
the mayor the mayor voted for it and and
the whole room went oh and then some
people outside cheered the protesters
yeah you're trying to get a brew and
he's like look I'm going to approve this
but if you [__] this up one [__]
mistake one one game mistake out there
in the park and I'm never gonna we're
never gonna have this again like you do
this every year like you go look at
Chicago Chicago has a huge has a huge
Pride scene in Pride event San Francisco
of course has a huge one uh uh you know
Denver like all of these different
states have massive events that happen
right oh man Google
what because they got a list what is the
gayest City biggest cities
um but it's just one of those things you
know so I I you want to know what it is
you want to know what it is okay so
here's here's uh oh [__] I lost it there
um here's Atlanta here's the top four
I guess what
LGBT population rank City
okay one way to say San Francisco what
the [__] is number one no well that's
that's backwards
Salt Lake City I feel like is one right
I feel like I saw that so we I said that
on the show a couple months ago oh
that's right that's right yeah we did
talk about that yeah okay so let's see
here let's see okay so number one the
top now this is the most
LGBT friendly friendly Coke okay
um so you know accepting allies San
Francisco number one number two New York
City okay number three is uh Fort
Lauderdale Florida oh that's got a
booster on De Santa
um number four is Denver Colorado so it
is in the top five number five is
um Northampton Massachusetts so you know
what's um what's funny six is Portland
Oregon but seven is Austin Texas and
eight is Chicago so Austin Texas which
is a pretty liberal City yeah yeah um is
is more friendly according to this poll
here right right
um then
it's just it I don't know it's like I'm
I'm surprised and not surprised at the
same time that all these people don't
know apps they just don't know absolute
[__] about this stuff right when they're
like oh man I'm loving this information
okay go ahead go ahead no go ahead
they're like they're like uh you know
when Republicans are like I love this uh
country singer and they're like oh that
country singer said they support black
lives right because black lives do
matter and they're like oh no I can't
cancel them they're like Harry Styles
wore a dress oh man [__] cancel them
Bud Light supports the vaccine in 2021
[__] cancel them and then they drank
the beer again up until 2023 we're like
this shit's gay as [__] and then they
cancel them again and they're like I'm
drinking coolers Coors is like cool but
we've been gay since 1978. we love gay
people yeah they're like dude uh you do
you know why our demographic is so high
dude do you know why Coors loves gay
people in Denver is because they have
one of the largest Pride parades in the
country and Coors is the [__] sponsor
no and the reason why is because they
sell a shitload of beer to gay people
yeah and for gay celebrations man it
ain't just gay people that love to
celebrate Pride man there's a lot of
people that get wasted [__] drunk
it's some [__] that's amazing that that
all these Republicans they do not do
their research and look into this to be
like it's just you know like I I did a I
did what was that on Donald Trump going
to the UFC fight and at the UFC fight
Kid Rock was wearing a Coors jacket and
it's like all these people try to own
the [__] lips and be like I'm never
drinking beer again I'm gonna shoot up
that [__] beer and I'm gonna wear a
Coors jacket which again since 1978 they
had initiative ever that has supported
lgbtq plus uh causes they [__]
supported AIDS research HIV research
like all of this stuff this is this is
not new again but Republicans for
whatever reason they're like oh NPR that
shit's woke as [__] they're trying to
take over our government or they're
trying to take over Society with the
tyrannical government you know
preachings it's like dude this is a
document that you guys [__] uh live
and die by you say right then you got
people who want to talk about the Beards
like you guys don't know [__] about beer
when you're trying to when you're trying
to talk uh uh how it's it's bad or it's
woke or it's gay or it's whatever you
know also the fact it's like dude
drinking the beer isn't gonna do [__] to
you guys okay like that's not even the
best kind of beer you're you're spending
hey hey he's on the dollar easy
[__] I'm from Missouri I'm just
saying it's not the best kind of beer oh
for the money you can buy for the money
you can buy right so okay let's talk
about this let's let's
what because I know what you're gonna
say
I know a beer you're gonna pick already
because you're from [__] Chicago what
what's which one's better not not gay
not on on the scale of rainbow right
because they're terrified of rainbows
but as far as taste is it Coors Light is
it Bud Light or is it Miller Light
hmm Coors Bud Miller I know what you're
gonna say just say it everyone knows
what you're gonna say you're from
Chicago man no beer is regional beer is
regional I don't give a [__] I I'm gonna
say Coors really yeah um you live out
west now no no no no you drank the Coors
Kool-Aid I drank Coors Light in college
as well as Miller life in Wisconsin yeah
but you also have to remember what
though man my camera's on a [__]
delay right now but you also have to you
also have to remember that when I was in
college Miller and Coors they merged
right so at the time you know you know
you know one of the reasons for that
I mean it was just uh no because Coors
Coors was out west and Coors wanted
National Distribution right Miller
Miller Miller was one of the ones that
could deliver National Distribution to
him right right I mean because because
before before before
we had these national beer brands beer
was Regional and the reason why is
because there weren't [__]
refrigerators a long time ago so it was
done by ice truck right so so it was and
the beer would go bad if you didn't keep
that [__] cold so you had to [__]
keep it cold so it you can only go so
[__] far right to keep the [__]
beer cold to keep it good and in other
words tasting good I mean people would
drink skunk beer hell I'll drink some
kind of beer right you get you [__]
wasted but I mean to keep it from not
skunking out you had to keep it cold
well ice [__] melts so so like how
far you can take it to keep it cold is a
problem so that's why beer
became Regional because these breweries
would pop up so they could sell
regionally right I mean there's like
that's why a lot of Brands don't exist
anymore even if they existed they've
been bought up by by mbev which owns
Budweiser or these other companies that
own these beers or these these beverage
caps but they don't even know that right
they don't even know the fact that
they're like oh I'm drinking a
european-owned company or beer right no
man no it's it's a germ inbev is German
European are you saying that Brian I
know but I listen we said this the other
day and I had one of my friends who's
from Europe Germany but he's like hey
[__] and Belgium
are you sure yeah yeah I think if I look
up inbev right now all right look it up
I'm telling you he [__] texts me he's
like don't say that [__] in your mouth
ever again so yeah it's a belgium-based
company there you go [__] and Brazilian
Village ambev and they'll work together
and it's called maybe inbev is the
parents originally a Nazi but you also
have to remember too that like in Bev
owns [__] everything Modelo Grupo
Modelo right Stella products yeah dude
they they own all this stuff well the
reason the reason why they own it all is
because Capital gets together and jerks
each other off right yeah I mean that's
why and also like if they're gonna
complain about stuff like oh uh
Budweiser or Coors or this and that I
mean like dude the very thing that you
[__] live and die by right all right
all right everyone's saying it's Belgium
I got it it's Bill yeah yeah it's
Belgium yeah yeah let me let me look up
this text message because
um
hey let's see hmm
oh yeah okay so he it's right he was
correcting me we said German yeah yeah I
know after that when I looked it up I
was like oh now now I remember when you
said it's from Germany and it's actually
right yeah yeah he was correcting me
yeah so see I I got it backwards [__] me
but like what am I gonna do just to give
you an idea like this is how little they
know about the company he's like man
[__] you know like for for uh Kid Rock
he's like football light and [__]
hazardous have a good day bro really
what he should have said was like [__]
Anheuser-Busch inbev which is that one
right or [__] all the other beers
because I can't drink any beer because
it's all gay
do you know how many cases of beer Kid
Rock would have to buy to shoot up
you know who you know actually I didn't
know this I didn't know this because I
had to look it up the other day because
it would for years it was called Miller
Coors right right because of the merger
right however uh a new company now
anheuser-boy oh she's like so many
[__]
Anheuser-Busch inbev s-a-n-v
subsequently sold sab's Miller Coors
beer company to Molson Coors uh and sold
many of the European Brands to Asahi
breweries I didn't know that either like
this like everyone's [__] training
well that's the other thing too is they
don't change the [__] brand that
right buying they're buying the brand
it's called it's called Molson Coors now
not Miller cores right but there is
Miller core still but it's owned by it's
like yeah but they're buying the [__]
brand they're not no no yeah yeah
it's Capital it's money buying the brand
so they can profit off of it guess what
also happens when you have the profit
motive you try to sell to the most
amount of people and when you're trying
to sell the most amount of people hate
doesn't really sell anymore I don't know
if people notice this I mean it does on
the right for their little cult but but
it doesn't sell I mean you you wouldn't
want Bud Light cans with [__] the KKK
in hoods on it right like it just well
definitely some people might wow right
but I'm saying but like might not sell
that much Bud Light if they did right
right because hate doesn't sell it or if
they put you know Nazi flags on Coors
Light if you want to know who knows you
want to know who mostly is now I didn't
even know this for because I thought it
was always Miller Coors that was the way
that I talked about it right do you know
who Molson Coors is who's they're a
Canadian American multinational drink
okay hold on wait wait so Molson course
because I didn't know this part was
formed in 2005 they were more a merger
of Molson of Canada and Coors of the US
right so distribution that way they made
that one that was Molson course and then
there was Miller cores that happened in
2008 2009 something like that I forget
then in 2016 Molson Coors the Canadian
American one acquired the Miller Brewing
Company for approximately 12 billion and
then the agreement made Molson core is
the world's third largest Brewer so then
you wrap up all of that [__] so it's
like again you wouldn't know these
things that happen in the background you
of course during course and you say oh
yeah this [__] course man and you
know it's you know cores owns them but
really they don't own them or someone
else owns them just like someone's like
Bud Light and there's a bush it's
actually not Anheuser-Busch it's
actually inbev that owns them and
they've owned them for uh going on
longer 12 13 14 years something like
that like the the fact that all these
people are like oh man I I live and die
I love this [__] I love it man this is
the thing I'm I mean I don't even know
who owns it I've been a fan since I was
born man I've been suppling on that
titty of that that that Bud Light since
I was a kid I know exactly 12 different
companies that own the beer that you
think is one all the time they keep
switching hands somebody acquired them
another one coming they sold that then
they acquired that another woman's
merged and formed it's just all of this
like Republicans don't know [__] they
talk a big game they're like the people
who are like oh man I'm the biggest fan
and you're like can you name me one
player on the team and like
can you name me the city they playing
well you know so there's like a bunch of
people that play the sport right and
they like travel so it's like it's a
sports ball thing yeah if that's what it
is it's these people that claim to be
the biggest fans right they're [__]
die hard fans and then you ask them a
simple question and they don't know
anything about it right the beer the
[__] Constitution Declaration of
Independence all of this stuff this is a
pattern this is a pattern one look I'll
show you this is Jim Jordan on his
latest not knowing beer or how crime
Works
um he's gonna go to New York and hold a
hearing about crime in New York which he
is and isn't he from Ohio he's got a lot
of problems in Ohio I mean even there
was a truck I don't know if you saw this
there was a truck that was removing the
uh these soiled dirt from the spill in
East Palestine and guess what happened
I did it spill yeah it spilled on the
road
they picked up a bunch of of of toxic
dirt yeah and and land moved it and then
they had a spill put it over the highway
and then they dumped into a new area
where they're like now we got to dig up
this [__] Jesus I gotta put in the truck
yeah he's [__] guys so he says he
says in a tweet latest Manhattan crime
headline suspect shot after 17 year old
shot and injured police investigating
the shots fired Hell's Kitchen man shot
he picked out three headlines with crime
in it in New York right gate now let me
show you let me show you um
this is a report from Mansfield Ohio
you've never even heard of that spot you
are man's you know who represents man's
field Jim Jordan yeah yes
um why is Mansfield Ohio called danger
City
Mansfield is one of the highest overall
crime rates of any U.S city
comparison the national total crime rate
is 2 489 incidents for every 100 000
people Mansfield overall crime rate is a
hundred percent higher than the overall
crime rate in the state of Ohio wow this
is the district so instead of going to
Mansfield to talk about [__] crime
Jim Jordan is gonna go to New York where
he can pick out three headlines of crime
in in New York
it's what a [__] idiot oh so I didn't
know this
um
CB over on uh on Twitch says
that that is where they film Shawshank
a danger City and yeah and man no [__]
Mansfield Ohio was where they filmed
Shawshank Redemption why are you having
[__] me and there's the prison
that's the prison that's there what the
[__] that's crazy I didn't know that
yeah that's great that's great wow the
internet the internet is a [__]
and it's it's just forever man it is oh
my God you say something it's there man
it's a [__] for these
Republicans yeah especially when it's
all video and you're like you guys
literally said this on video I got one
more fact I want to point out here
Elizabeth on Facebook says Tony has the
prettiest blue eyes oh man that's you
know thank you Elizabeth thank you
Elizabeth yeah I I know there it's a
filter though it's not real yeah it's a
[__] Instagram this is all film
Beauty filter yeah all filters
oh God he's like [__] 78 years old
dude shriveled up like balls
okay
oh my God you look better than Rupert
Murdoch but you know whatever how else
should we end the show then to talk
about my wrinkled up old balls good Lord
what what a show
though somebody somebody said wait and
see Tony's drunk ass eyes tomorrow
everybody knows what happens on
Wednesday like everyone knows Wednesday
night's a [__] crazy night last week
I wasn't drunk though well I did drink a
little bit but I wasn't drunk I I I I
wouldn't take the first day you came to
show and you were like I was high as
[__] oh Stone I was stoned to the Bone
the night before okay okay
I went to [__] Stone City man yeah
man [__] dangerous city I went to Stone
City no so I but I'm not going to be
doing that anymore okay at the bar at
the bar getting stoned getting stoned it
was good listen
so when you sing karaoke right you have
a certain Tempo it's a song right the
song but when I was stoned that song
lasted forever like I was like I've been
singing for an hour this is weird like
it felt like I was singing for an hour
and it's like a two-minute song Right
were people like uh uh like you you saw
like was it that you were seeing the
yellow pass over the words on like the
white letters and you're like uh and
then you just felt like one forever or
were you really holding notes and people
were like no no no no it felt like like
it was in real time it was the same time
that it always is and apparently it
sounded all right I mean to me let's see
though let's see the video Let's see the
tape man to me I sounded fantastic I
sounded fantastic as far as I'm
concerned and other people said no you
know you know that matters as long as
you feel that you sounded fantastic then
you're okay but it it took forever to
sing a song and it was like 30 years
between song and song right yeah that's
why you're 78 now right that's true that
maybe that's why you have this filter
and you're like look I gotta look young
because in one night it was like a big
effect you just like [__] aged I I
would I want to dispute the last comment
because even though my my eyes on
Thursdays may be bloodshot they're still
the pretty blue okay they're like they
got a little pink to them right it's
just they're just a little bloodshot
maybe yeah yeah and a little hungover
speaking of Thursday tomorrow is a
special day we're playing hide and seek
we're playing hide and seek
um so go subscribe right now to Gabe
Sanchez's YouTube channel youtube.com I
am Gabe Sanchez it's youtube.com I am
Gabe Sanchez go right now
to subscribe because we're gonna be
there tomorrow now if you're one who
looks for the link because because what
I'll do is I'll post the link on the
community tab on upwire and my channel
so you can find it here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna play hide and seek
tomorrow but we're telling you where the
hiding spot is so you can come chat on
Gabe's YouTube channel but we want you
to subscribe there uh we're trying to
get everyone there so we can support
Gabe on his YouTube channel so remember
tomorrow the chat on YouTube is going to
be on Gabe Sanchez's YouTube channel so
don't forget to subscribe right now
youtube.com I am Gabe Sanchez also
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
if you haven't already what the [__] are
you doing also download every single
episode of the Tony Michaels podcast
every single weekday Monday through
Friday after I get it edited up on the
directory's Apple Spotify and Google
it's free over there also what is free
99 is to tie your Amazon Prime account
to your Twitch account if you get one
free subscription with your Amazon Prime
account
if you link it to your Twitch account we
get a couple bucks don't forget anyone
who has done this
subscribed with their Amazon Prime
account you got to go back in and renew
it every month for us to get the money I
know it's pain in the ass but it's 12
times a year just go in renew it we get
the couple bucks Bezos tries to make it
hard for you I just want to give away
them I want to get more money away I
mean he's like not so not so fast so you
just go in like you did before and just
again renew the subscription to the Tony
Michaels podcast on Twitch and you'll
get it also if you're on Facebook still
you still have an account at the Tony
Michaels and make sure this weekend is
going to be a special weekend you're
gonna do a patreon thing on Saturday
right yeah yeah I think I think I might
join you if I can on Jump On In Baby I
might join you so go to what was that
show.com or go to patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez check out his patreon over there
while you're there check out my patreon
page patreon.com the Tony Michaels I'm
gonna have a patreon party this weekend
and everyone who's a member everyone
who's a member is going to be invited so
you might watch me get high or drunk and
sing karaoke see
so that's going to be on Sunday we
usually do a Sunday rant but I'm gonna
do a it's gonna be a long patreon party
it's gonna be like a zoom meeting so
you'll be able to see talk oh okay okay
you know me again maybe I'll get uh you
know that sounds fun maybe I'll maybe
I'll Zoom bomb you yeah there you go
show up I'm gonna [__] I'll get a
little loaded and sink karaoke for you
[__] so uh come come to patreon.com
the Tony Michaels or patreon.com I am
Gabe Sanchez check out our patreon page
again this Saturday Gabe will have a q a
maybe I'll join and then Sunday maybe
he'll join when I get loaded and sing
karaoke party
could get a little weekend
seven days
holy [__] okay so go to patreon.com the
Tony Michaels or patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez you know where we're gonna be
tomorrow we're gonna be not same time
same time but not the same place
remember we're gonna be on Gabe
Sanchez's YouTube channel don't forget
yet don't forget youtube.com I am Gabe
Sanchez don't forget to go over there
same time tomorrow dinner place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon